[Musique]
où
histoire grande faut d'autres qui en
faire il se tenir bien enfouis porte des
enfers toi tu vivais comme si tu voulais
contentèrent ton coeur on appelait ça
des océans n'en fait com site en anglais
seulement comment fais tu repenses à ta
faute tu sais que tu as les mains
ainsi qu'autour de défaut des remorques
élément tient expérience ailleurs dans
la même peine wendel que tu portement
que le néon et atteignent
et en fixant plafond pendant les arbres
[Musique]
et dans fixant plats vont bon train
résonnent à
peur de la mort pire que tout s'arrête
la vie n'est qu'un seul
mais surtout mme a compris que tu t'en
bandonéon du mois j'ai perdu mon frère
et aux femmes nées en fils
[Musique]
ta famille
s
à
[Musique]
e
tu montes ont pu se méritait pas avancer
[Musique]
je ne tends
elle a même avancé
le
[Musique]
tu n'entends plus
cependant tous des revirements dont
pas
[Musique]
ce n'est pas que les couteaux qui
25 et tu vas les serres de tout miser
sur le plancher
et de l'alcool dans ses pensées et dans
piques sont plaints bandana
[Musique]
hélas
oh
tu nous
[Musique]
te
dans ce cas
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et moi qui comptais sur mineurs et moi
qui croyais comptes tu ne t'en veux
faire roger était millions dépassant 2 à
tester décrire de façon ce test de toi
[Musique]
sur deux
que de mai
je pense que la gauche tu m'as mis à la
mode et joe réputé mais j'aurais pu t
même et je ré différents crédits à la
banque
mettez des chaufferettes chevret comme
un mcflurry est longue mais toi tu veux
mais moi je termine mais j'aimais ton
piercing à la langue tu veux devenir
tu veux débit alors tu t'es mise en
revendre des niveaux de bénéfices
je commence à me les défis oui je t'aime
mais jamais vu
quand je t'ai vu tu peux dire c est moi
qui croyais qu'on nomme un millénaire et
moi qui croyais compter du numéro vert
bleu rouge aux passants
raison
[Musique]
du coup
oui mais bon j'ai pas son poste hier
d'amy
passons
toi
le sort
[Musique]
émue pour 2010
ma confiance en poche
non non non comment tu vas tu en voilà
tyco honnêtement tu m'appelles seul
nassim pour les intimes et je suis très
content d'être parmi vous ce soir ça
donne un truc de ouf de pouvoir jouer
quand même parce que j'ai les temps qui
courent du coup du coup je vous remercie
pour tous à cette organisation de fou et
en échange je vais en profiter pour vous
inviter dans mon univers ont montré hier
[Musique]
comme un élément elle mon coeur je les
mange vraiment
tellement de l'amant de demander des
menteurs les étourdis l'inter c'est moi
qui m'en faire autant
pas content
[Musique]
pas bon
marine
sourire
plus d'émotion je sais tu dis moi qui tu
regardes et s'entretuent
j'ai eu envie de lui dire c'est plus par
dj dans le vent non c'est beaucoup mieux
que d'avoir dîné dans le fond comme le
nord et le monde
seulement je ne mords
monde
[Musique]
tellement de la menthe le monde ait des
morts
les menteurs comme argument important
[Musique]
monde
toujours
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
on
[Rires]
[Musique]
le
du
[Musique]
j'aimerais tu n'aimes interdite rue en
faisant la fête dure tanker est en passe
un jour tout ce temps c'est cela faire
un truc bête comme de dire que je te
donne
juste pour tu me rends j'aimerais
vraiment
moche mais je suis bon que pour choeur
par l'internaute de se fâcher
j'ai beaucoup burgas
quand tu t'entends
ce que l'au delà et fait sens que tout
cela a du sens pour moi quand dans mon
coeur
du sang sont supprimés mais sachant 300
me sens fort et toi tu mens france
gervais ce ton bon
écoutez leurs solutions j'aimerais vider
ma tête d'oublier pendant la fête mais
j'attends que d'en bas
un jour de se
je voudrais faire un truc comme de dire
que je
bourque du mois
manque de rome marge mais je suis bon
que morgan
comme à plein de ce marché
non
tu mon cas m'engage
pourquoi tu te donnes
j'ai moins envie démentent être doublée
en fait mais j'attends d'eux
comme si un jour de retard sur audrey
entre peine comme te dire que je te
déteste
pour que tu remarques j'aimerais
vraiment aura marche mais jurons que
bongo
à
je
pas la peine de sa fille
jean
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que tu veux danser avec moi
c'est sans danger bien conditions c'est
pas trop ça mais
non tu en as tu est un petit peu mais on
ne veut jamais un jour chez l'évangile
et non
despentes eux mêmes
comment fumio dans son berceau pierre
qui s'efface ans est en déficit pire
tant que je ressens c'est tout le monde
prend tout son sens en tout et pour tout
que deux temps forts qu'il est également
qu'ils aient peur de tout
qui ne vit que pour le monde il ya plus
de deux mois plus tôt que c'est gênant
[Musique]
là
plus jeune
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
plusieurs voix
foot
[Musique]
plus que jo
le membre à ces mots que je t'en parle
[Musique]
j'ai peur des problèmes dans les trains
tu ne que pourvu que ces menteurs
en plus d'oxygène dans
[Musique]
à
roy
[Musique]
que
sans faire sentir à faire sentir a peur
sans tuner de les sentir un peu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je mangeais dans le jeu
[Applaudissements]
aucune
à gaza
[Musique]
diab le sol permettant aussi intense
quand tout mensonge
j'avais mon défi d'apprendre tout
moisson
exempt de toute façon voté pour de même
dimension
l'opposante
poussés
les ports de nantes d'effacer le
concédant
[Musique]
dans ce
g
m
[Musique]
nouveauté
jean rivière des galets
[Musique]
la jambe aux machines de jeu les
commentaires je me tape débats quelques
affaires leur siège me démarque de ses
concerts des black stars et la star car
ce n'est pas l'abondance de l'état n'en
est pas quitte en où vivent de 500 m à
l'est pas ça fait tous les jours pour
que cet événement s'est sentie aussi
vous souhaitez morts
mention des droits des parents
vim
parce que
en fait morte ans
tentant la première fois edward et
connaît personne et on arrose la
programmation la première fois
après c'est comme à mouiller la cct si
dans votre vie des villes de plus ce
match doit déranger car si jean m'énerve
et me dégage de l'énergie
[Musique]
ma
monsanto
morte en supportant le fut
juncker
bonjour
en cours
[Musique]
comme un fou
la soupe
[Musique]
tant puma
pourtant c'est important
[Musique]
depuis 20 ans je faisais ce que ça va
pour ce soir pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on n'a rien avait fait sa job
et avant de partir j'aimerais vous dire
quelques mots ça me tient à coeur
déjà j'aimerais vous remercier
les ingés light les injections qui sont
présents dans la salle tantôt d'un
discours au 6 rue des fantômes
glaciologue merci à ceux qui s'occupent
de la salle
merci à ceux qui organisent les sinois
merci à toute l'équipe toutes les
personnes qui sont là les personnes du
jury ceux qui ont chanté juste avant moi
ceux qui s'en convaincre que moi
j'aimerais que vous le remerciez
énormément et aussi j'aimerais
maintenant d'un pourrissement mon
guitariste à main gauche et partant un
cadeau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à ma droite et john obi wan et en terre
d'islam ou simplement
[Musique]
cette dernière chanson s'intitule larsen
sorte de cercle vicieux
dans le sombre revient dans le micro au
pire ou pas comme enceinte mais ça me
rappelle un peu les stores de ma vie
peut-être de la vôtre alors j'ai fait la
présenter
je suis à ma manière
je
[Musique]
oooh
non
à
[Musique]
oh
dit que l'enfer ces désordres
mais les autres
qu'on nous noté mort c'est dans ma tête
ça fait de l'art
dit que non
ces deux ans
de ses mains comme nos deux mondes
moi dans ma tête ça fait de l'argent
[Musique]
c'est tout
j'en entends qui disent que les temps
changent disent que va miser sur des
tangentes les gens qui pouvaient partir
les des manchots qui bosse à ronsard
l'univers des tendances je ne sais pas
qui volent et salomé qui laisse en
faveur des bleus qui dans ma tête des
protos et ça c'est pas sur terre
dimanche hull en fait
[Musique]
cela
m
[Musique]
vers le mali nous
le maniement sur l'homme
titre
ap
on veut se développer
on dit que c'est
non
le
orange com
[Musique]
cet énoncé
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous